양자 학습 플랫폼에서요. 이 튜토리얼에서 알아두실 점은, 노트북 초반에 나중에 편하게 사용할 수 있는
헬퍼 함수 시리즈를 만들어 뒀다는 거예요. 이걸 언급하는 이유는 공식 프로세스의 일부여서가 아니라,
실제로 실험가들이 이런 종류의 실험을 운영할 때 자주 사용하는 방법이기 때문이에요.
또 문제를 어떻게 더 세분화하는지도 보여줘요.
노트북에서 정의하는 함수들은 다음과 같아요. qubit 커플링 제거,
qubit 커플링 정의, 레이어 커플링 구성, 얽힘 레이어 구성, 마지막으로 트로터화된
circuit 정의예요. 다음으로 레이어 커플링에 대해 이야기해 봐요. 레이어 커플링은 시뮬레이션 중에 qubit이
이웃 qubit들과 어떻게 상호작용하는지 정의하는 데 도움을 줘요. 우리의 양자 디바이스는 헤비 헥사고날이라고 불리는
레이아웃을 사용해요. qubit을 연결하는 특별한 패턴이에요. 이 레이아웃에서는 엣지라고 불리는 연결들을 같은 집합 내에서
두 연결이 qubit을 공유하지 않는 세 개의 분리된 집합으로 그룹화할 수 있어요.
이게 중요한 이유는 실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 같은 qubit을 포함하는 2-qubit gate를 동시에
실행할 수 없기 때문이에요. 각 qubit은 한 번에 하나의 gate에만 참여할 수 있어요.
모든 연결을 세 개의 레이어로 나눔으로써, 전체 디바이스에서 세
번의 라운드로 2-qubit gate를 적용할 수 있고, 레이어당 하나의 gate에만 qubit이 사용되도록 할 수 있어요.
이 gate들은 이징 모델의 ZZ 상호작용을 구현하며, 트로터
단계라고 불리는 시뮬레이션의 각 단계에서 반복돼요. 트월링은 디바이스의 노이즈를 수정해서 단순한 노이즈 모델조차도
정확할 가능성을 높여요. 또한 노이즈 모델을 정확하게 학습하고 얻은
정보와 오류 완화 기법을 사용하는 것도 가능하게 해줘요.
다음으로, 실험에 사용할 수 있는 물리적 qubit 목록에서 불량 qubit을 제거해야 해요.
앞서 말씀드린 것처럼, qubit은 다양한 이유로 불량이 될 수 있어요. 때로는 단순히 잘못된
보정으로 인한 것이라서 다시 보정하면 해결되는 단순한 실수예요.
때로는 좀 더 복잡해서 TLS라고 부르는 것과 관련이 있는데, 이는 2-레벨 계면
결함으로 qubit 매개변수 변동과 이완을 일으켜요.
이는 전체 시스템을 약간 가열했다가 다시 냉각하면 해결되는데, 시간이 좀 걸리고 클라우드에서는
할 수가 없어요. 그래서 지금은 그냥 사용할 물리적 qubit 목록에서 제외하는 게 가장
쉬운 방법이에요. IBM 양자 플랫폼에서 어떤 qubit이 예상대로 작동하지 않는지 쉽게 파악할 수 있어요.
플랫폼에서 qubit 특성을 플롯하거나 CSV로 다운로드할 수 있어요. 그런 다음 제외하고 싶은 모든
qubit 목록을 만들고 디바이스의 전체 물리적 qubit 목록에서 간단히 제거하면 돼요.
좋아요. 이제 트로터화된 circuit을 생성하는 매핑 단계를 계속해 봐요. 앞서 보여드린 것처럼
트로터화는 시간 진화를 일련의 단계로 이산화하는데, 단계 수를 결정해야 해요.
여기서는 여섯 단계를 선택할 거예요. 하지만 일반적인 전략은 트로터 오류라고 불리는 것의 균형을 맞추는 건데,
이는 결어긋남에서 발생하는 오류와의 알고리즘 근사 오류예요. 트로터 단계가 많을수록 근사
오류는 줄어들지만 더 많은 결어긋남 노이즈를 경험하는 더 깊은 quantum circuit이 필요해요. circuit을
theta 매개변수, 즉 외부 자기장의 세기, 레이어 커플링, 그리고
단계 수와 qubit 수, 물론 디바이스 backend를 기준으로 정의할 거예요.
외부 자기장의 세기에 따른 시스템 자화의 의존성 때문에, 다양한 자기장 세기 값에서
시뮬레이션을 실행하는 게 흥미로운데, 이는 circuit에서의 RX 회전의
다양한 각도로 변환돼요. circuit을 생성했으니 이제 최적화로 넘어갈게요.
여기서 첫 번째 단계는 pass manager를 정의하는 거예요. Qiskit SDK의 맥락에서 transpilation은
입력 circuit을 양자 디바이스에서 실행하기에 적합한 형태로 변환하는 과정이에요.
Transpilation은 일반적으로 transpiler 패스라고 불리는 일련의 단계로 이루어져요. pass manager는
transpiler 패스 목록을 저장하고 circuit에서 실행할 수 있는 객체예요. transpiler 패스 목록으로
pass manager 객체를 초기화해서 pass manager를 만들 수 있어요. 결국 pass manager는
ISA circuit을 만드는데, 이는 backend의 instruction set architecture 형태로 작성된 circuit으로,
backend에 네이티브한 circuit과 gate를 설명하지만 circuit을 실행하는 데 필요한 타이밍 정보는 없어요.
이제 Qiskit 패턴의 3단계인 circuit 실행 준비가 됐어요. 앞서 말씀드린 것처럼 시스템의
전체 자화를 측정하고 싶기 때문에 이 실험에서는 estimator를 프리미티브로 사용할 거예요.
관측량의 기댓값을 추정하는 게 estimator가 설계된 목적이기 때문이에요.
이 단계에서 오류 완화 옵션을 지정하는 것도 중요해요. 최상의 결과를 얻기 위해 제로 노이즈 외삽을 사용할 거예요. 특히 튜토리얼에서는
외삽 모델을 평가할 두 개 이상의 노이즈 인자 값을 지정하고
확률적 오류 증폭을 증폭 옵션으로 지정하는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
확률적 오류 증폭, 즉 PA는
다른 옵션들보다 훨씬 더 잘 확장되기 때문에 여기서 선택한 오류 완화 기법이었어요.
100개 이상의 qubit 수준에서 작업할 때 중요한 점이에요.
마지막으로 실험을 실행하면 완료하는 데 시간이 걸리는데, 지금은 튜토리얼에서 큐에 등록되고 저장된
데이터를 참조할게요. 메타데이터를 검토하면서 레이어드 gate와 원시 데이터에서 많은 오류를 제거하는 데 사용할
완화된 레이어에 특히 주목할 거예요. 최종 결과를 플롯할 준비가 거의 됐는데, 그 전에
제로 노이즈 외삽이 정확히 무엇을 의미하는지에 대해 잠깐 이야기해 봐요.
이전 에피소드에서 간략히 다뤘는데, 복습하자면 제로 노이즈 외삽, 즉 ZNE는
circuit 실행 중 알 수 없는 노이즈의 영향을 제거하는 오류 완화 기법으로, 노이즈를
알려진 방식으로 조정할 수 있어요. 기댓값이 여기에 표시된 알려진 함수에 의해 노이즈와 함께 스케일된다고 가정해요.